now you may recall that shea stepped
down as ceo of zappos earlier this year
but
for years he was a driving force in the
revitalization of downtown las vegas
those impacted by his passing are now
trying to find ways to honor what he did
for this city
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
live from the zappos headquarters
with details on a petition created in
his honor
madison
[Music]
yes a new petition has been circulating
the web getting the attention of las
vegas officials
and we spoke to the man who started it
all
las vegas still reeling over the passing
of entrepreneur and las vegas resident
tony shea several local business owners
speaking out about their experiences
with
shea and all he did for the downtown
area of the city
but one man took it a step further and
created a petition on
change.org his mission renamed part of
sixth street to tony shea way
the man johnny moscow a former las vegas
local
who now lives in honolulu hawaii heard
the news of his passing and knew he had
to do something
i saw the impact that he made on not
just our city but
the first thing that hit me was wow like
the impact that he made on
my my my close family friends the
change.org petition that was just posted
a couple days ago
has already reached its goal of over 2
500 signatures
i think it would be appropriate just to
name it north of fremont where he had
the most impact around the zappos and
downtown
las vegas area so a building i don't
think would keep the
lasting legacy that he's created and las
vegas mayor carolyn goodman agrees that
something should be named in his honor
maybe a park or an art installation
something fitting of a man who had such
a profound
impact on so many people like kathy
brooks
i don't know that i ever really told him
how grateful i was that's what i've been
thinking about this weekend
i know i thanked him but i don't know
that i ever really fully expressed to
him how grateful i am
brooks owns the hydrant club a dog
training center right off of ninth
street and fremont
she accredits shea for giving her the
courage to live out her dream
and leave the tech world behind it's
just wrong that he's gone
he's too young it's too soon look at all
that he accomplished already and i think
about what could have been possible
and johnny moscow says he hopes that the
petition makes enough of an
impact that something will happen but of
course
that will be up to las vegas officials
what you're looking out now is
a memorial right here at zappos now
carolyn goodman the mayor
obviously is probably going to discuss
this at wednesday's
city council meeting so we will look out
for that reporting live from zappos
madison kimbrough 8 news now